[Music]
in their ramshackle Hut on the edge of
the woods a husband and wife were in
despair the woman had just given birth
to their 30th
child and the growing family was quickly
running out of food and money
the father walked into the woods to
ponder their problem after hours spent
wandering through the trees he
encountered two shadowy silhouettes the
first appeared to be the man's God while
the second resembled the devil
both figures offered to lighten the
man's burden and act as godfather to his
most recent child but the man refused
their offer
he wouldn't entrust his son to those who
passed judgment on human life he
ventured deeper into the tangled thicket
here in the darkest part of the woods
the father made out a third figure
sunken eyes stared out of its gaunt face
it broke into a crooked smile this was
death himself come to offer his services
as Godfather he promised to return when
a child came of age to bring him
happiness and prosperity the father
knowing that all people are equal in the
eyes of death accepted his offer years
later when the child had grown into
ambitious young man his skeletal
Godfather came for his promised visit in
his gnarled hand he held a flask
containing the cure for all human
ailments death had brought this flask
for his godson promising to make him a
successful doctor but the powerful
potion came with very strict rules if
his godson encountered a sick person and
death was hovering at the top of their
bed the doctor could heal them with just
a waft of the antidotes fumes but if
death lingered at the foot of the bed
he'd already claimed the patient as his
own and the doctor could do nothing for
them in time the doctors potent potion
and uncanny instincts became known
throughout the land
he grew rich and famous casting off the
hardships of his early life when the
King fell ill he summoned of a famous
physician to treat him the doctor swept
into the palace ready to show off his
skills but when he entered the King's
Chamber he was dismayed to see death
settled at the foot of the bed the
doctor desperately wanted the glory of
saving the king even if it meant
deceiving his godfather and so he
swiftly spun the bed around and reversed
death's position leaving the doctor free
to administer the antidote death was
needed he warned his arrogant godson
that if he ever cheated death again he
would pay for it with his life death and
the doctor continued their travels after
some time the Kings messengers came to
collect the doctor yet again the
princess was gravely ill and the king
had promised incredible riches to anyone
who could cure her the doctor approached
the princess's chamber with gold in his
eyes but upon seeing the sleeping
princess his greed fell away
he was so struck by her grace that he
failed to notice death lurking by her
feet he swiftly healed the princess but
before she could even utter her thanks
death had dragged his lovesick godson
away in an instant the palace dissolved
around them the doctor found himself in
an immense cave lined with countless
quivering candles each representing the
duration of a life as punishment for his
godson's foolish attempt to master
mortality death whittled his candle down
to its wick seeing his own dwindling
light the doctor felt the fear he'd
often glimpsed in his patients eyes
desperately he begged death to transfer
his dying light onto a new candle his
Godfather considered the request but the
doctors betrayal was too great he
loosened his bony grip and his godson's
candle fell to the floor death stood
motionless his inscrutable face fixed on
the sputtering flame until all that was
left of the doctor was a wisp of smoke
the doctor wasn't the first to try to
cheat death and lose Sisyphus the first
king of ephyra twice escaped death by
tricking the gods unfortunately for him
there wouldn't be a third time find out
how his myth ends with this video
[Music]